all right guys we have a 2013 Honda CRV
that we want to go ahead and add a key
that's the original key in the ignition
and these are the two keys that we want
to cut that we want to add to the car so
uh we're going to go to manual selection
and we will go to
CRV blade
key and let's go to control unit
immobilizer
okay ignition is
on and the thing you should know about
these key the these cars that not
everybody knows sometimes people lose
all their keys um except let's say the
valet key and then they want to make a
key from there and you'll go ahead and
try to add Keys using the valet key
which is this one right here and you'll
just get a fail and not know what's
going on so the reason why is because
you can cannot use that key to add keys
to the car cuz it's a valet key so um
what you got to do is you got to just do
all keys lost and a registered key is
already in the ignition turned on we'll
just go ahead and turn it on again with
that key and just click
[Music]
okay and all you got to do is just
follow the instructions
[Music]
and you want to turn it on with the new
key so we'll put this aside and we'll
take one of the new keys put it in there
turn it
on and turn it
off on
off and what we want is that green light
to disappear turn it on
again and the green light
disappeared and that is now added to the
vehicle we know the programming was
success and did the lamp go out that's
talking about the green light and as I
showed you it did go out so we know
that's all good to
go and the current number of keys is now
four we'll say okay and now we want to
go ahead and this is now registered so
we'll add another key to the car um
using that key to register this but it's
the same process so you guys don't need
to see the rest of that and I'll show
you that the car starts here you go so
again do not use valet keys to add key
to the car because it will not work you
need to use an original um master key in
order to program so 2013 Honda
CRV uh added using the allel
im508 uh like subscribe and uh we're
here in Maryland if anybody needs
service